this is a campaign now to blame ben
shapiro for inciting a deadly terror
attack on a canadian mosque last year we
welcome back to the angle ben shapiro
the editor in chief of the daily walk
wire and he looks so unassuming and like
ben i don't know what do you weigh 150
pounds i mean you're like 165 and volume
on but i'm saying like you don't look
like all that intimidating i mean you
you write stuff and you go on TV but
explain how you are allegedly involved
in inspiring this horrible attack on a
mosque because you you you made comments
about islamic terror in the past and it
was all stitched together so there's
this evil piece of human crap who shot
up a mosque last year and this evil
piece of human crap happened to be
somebody who had seen some of my tweets
on twitter as prosecutors found now he'd
also seen tweets from people like bret
baier he's seen tweets from you he's
seen tweets from a bunch of different
people but it was I guess my account was
the one that he had viewed the most now
I have one point four million Twitter
followers so I guess the idea from the
left is that if somebody views enough of
my tweets they're inevitably going to
become a terrorist weird that I don't
have a spate of enormous terrorism
across the country thanks to my Twitter
following but of course none of this is
real I mean when when Bernie Sanders a
Bernie Sanders supporter shot up a
congressional baseball game people on
the right did not say this was Bernie
Sanders is fall Bernie Sanders inside
crazy person yeah we play fair and they
don't care about those rules so what
their goal is and this is why we bring
you on for this series their goal is to
intimidate other conservatives using you
as an abject lesson we're gonna use you
as an example don't speak out on these
issues because if you do it we don't
care we could be in you know even
doesn't matter for its in Canada or
Australia or anywhere else we are gonna
brand you a hater we're gonna try to
stop your livelihood stop you from
making money stop you from getting
speeches that's what this is about is it
not so it's this malcontents in Canada
who's kicking up a fuss we've seen it
with a Southern Poverty Law Center with
they're obscene list of Islamic you know
what is it Osama phobes or whatever it
I'm on I think I'm on that less
ridiculous but they don't want to shut
down speech
no question if you're gonna talk about
the SPLC by their same logic they're
responsible for the attack on the Family
Research Council a few years back since
the guy who shot up the Family Research
Council was it was a follower of the
SPLC and used their apparently their
their map of hate groups as a target so
all of this is really dangerous and all
of it is leading to an attempt in the
United States by people on the far left
to imitate what we've seen in places
like Britain in places like Canada to
actually shut down dissenting points of
view if those dissenting points of view
do not meet with the politically correct
standards of the left so the fact that
I've tweeted out about the evils of
radical Islam and I cut a video talking
about the percentage of Muslims
worldwide who may believe radical things
based on polling data from the Pew
Research Center now this apparently was
enough to blame me for a terrorist
attack that has nothing to do with me
that I have obviously denounced that was
as I say committed by an evil piece of
human debris but again all of this is
nonsense generated by the left
specifically in order to shut down free
speech that's their heart Kanye West has
become a very interesting figure on the
cultural scene no doubt expressing his
love for many people but among them most
controversially is Donald Trump and now
he's gotten attacked by everybody of
comments he made about slavery being a
choice which is not obviously what he
meant but now it turns out that we're
seeing perhaps connected we don't know a
increase in support among African
Americans especially African American
men double support - I guess the figure
is now it's up to 22 percent it was 11
percent approval now it's 22 percent
where the overall approval is also
increasing I believe to 16 percent from
8 percent that's interesting is it just
a coincidence here with Kanye West you
know it's impossible to tell obviously
whether it's a coincidence in this short
period of time but I will say this what
Kanye did by basically saying think for
yourself if that's such a threat to the
left it demonstrates how the left has to
use identity politics to shut down any
real debate listen I don't think that
Kanye West ought to be nominated for
head of the Heritage Foundation round
think the guy is spending his off hours
reading Frederick Hayek but what Kanye
did say here which is very simple is
listen I'm not just a black guy and I'm
not just a Hollywood celebrity I'm an
individual with my own thoughts and
feelings I get to
formulate my own logic and I also get to
figure out what I believe and if
everybody else thought like this then
perhaps we ought to be able to have
these conversations that we haven't been
able to have so far good for Kanye West
for at least beginning the conversation
I'm stunned that it's Kanye doing it but
the guy gets all the credit I mean it
print is a pretty amazing stand that
he's taking at a time when he doesn't
have to take it I just think he's trying
to say to people you don't have to be
imprisoned by your past as hard as it
was as abusive and unfair and unjust as
it was it doesn't have to define your
future and a lot of philosophers have
said that over the centuries and frankly
over the millennia you can create your
own identity Hillary Clinton was out
there yesterday with a day before
yesterday a QA about socialism America
whatever let's watch you may be the only
presidential candidate since World War
two that actually had to stand up and
say I am a capitalist and you did did it
hurt you probably I mean you know it's
it's it's hard to know but I mean if
you're in the Iowa caucuses and 41% of
Democrats are socialists or
self-described socialist and I'm asked
are you a capitalist and I say yes but
with appropriate regulation and
appropriate accountability you know that
that probably gets lost and though my
gosh she's a couple less all right been
like one sentence I'm she actually told
the truth good for Hillary she finally
stumbled across something that is true
and she said it Democrats are tending
part socialism what can you say